hello and welcome to the daily climate
show coming up
days of torrential rain brings massive
floods to sydney for the fourth time in
18 months
experts link a glacier collapse that
killed several hikers in italy to global
warming
and an important step for biodiversity a
new species of giant water lily is
discovered at london's kew gardens
[Music]
hello and welcome to the daily climate
show where we track the changes
happening to our planet hear from the
people hit hardest by those changes and
reports on the race for solutions so
first we start in australia where the
effects of global warming are being felt
once again after days of torrential rain
have forced thousands of people from
their homes for some residents in sydney
and the surrounding areas this is the
fourth time they've faced flooding in 18
months with extreme weather events that
were previously a once-in-a-generation
event becoming more commonplace
or more than 30 000 people have either
been asked to leave their homes or get
ready to do so and the new premiere of
new south wales has said that the number
could increase as the week goes on
dominic perite also said that emergency
services have made 116 flood rescues in
recent days
well it's the fourth major flooding
event in southeast australia in the last
year and a half with the weather in
march and april causing at least 2.7
billion pounds worth of damage our
correspondent nicole johnston reports
from windsor near sydney
a rescue on the outskirts of sydney this
family believed they could handle the
flood
but the water rose so fast before they
knew it the only way out was by boat
waking up at about 2am and seeing water
creeping up to the house it was
it was difficult sleeping but uh yeah no
it's it's definitely scary especially
with kids
already this year there's been multiple
floods in new south wales
and people are tired of it flood fatigue
there is covered footy this flood
fatigue get the woman with me
that's what i'm feeling the the two
words to describe it it's just
i'm just tired of the floods more than
30 000 people have been evacuated from
homes in and around sydney
or have been warned to get ready for it
as yet again australia's east coast is
battered by rain
a month's worth of it
in only two days it's incredible uh in
the last
18 months we've had three major flood
events in this area and we're talking
about water depths getting way above
head level in some areas and you know
multiple people having to be evacuated
animals needing to be rescued and also
people as well
wild weather saw a cargo ship stuck
without power
and drifting towards rocky sea cliffs
a helicopter rescue had to be aborted
eventually it was towed away from danger
this major bridge on the outskirts of
sydney has been lost under a mile wide
river and with the flood waters still
rising people are bracing themselves for
even more homes to go under
so they're getting ready
moving whatever they can to higher
ground or a shipping container
this is an area prone to flooding
but not this often
keith levy moved in here six months ago
since then
four floods
the ground floor is under a meter of
muddy water
he's given up bothering to pump it out
is this climate change
i think partially i think there's a lot
of factors i think damn management as
well is um
the cause of what's also going on and
also the human footprint we're putting
on
the area as well
with barely time to recover from one
flood the region is hit with another
it's been called sydney's new normal
but nothing feels normal about this
nicole johnston sky news
sydney
more than a dozen people are still
missing after a huge chunk of glacier
broke off in the italian alps yesterday
several people are reported to have been
killed when the ice fell from the
marmalade glacier unleashing a huge
avalanche of ice snow and rocks now
experts are pointing to climate change
as a calls for the tragedy in italy
because it's had heat waves in recent
weeks well sky's betty becky cotterell
is here can you tell us the latest becky
well we know that at least seven people
have died nine people have been injured
and it's thought at least 15 people are
missing and clearly the fear is that the
number of dead could rise following that
avalanche yesterday a huge chunk of a
glacier on the marmalade mountain broke
off and thundered down the mountain
slope to an area where people were
trekking and as you mentioned the signs
do point to climate change and i suppose
becky um there is a worry that as the
planet warms more events like this are
very possible yes scientists have said
it is inevitable that this will continue
to happen this glacier and many others
have been melting for decades but
recently temperatures have been
unseasonably warm just in recent days
temperatures at the peak top 10 degrees
celsius and for this area that is
classed as extreme heat and it
contributes to ice melting and obviously
in this case this avalanche taking place
and it's thought that if global
temperatures aren't kept below 1.5
degrees celsius then by the end of the
century all of italy's alpine glaciers
will have disappeared okay becky thanks
very much for
the update well let's get a bit more of
today's climate news now and there's
been some arrests over those go slow
convoys on the motorways across england
wells and scotland arranged by people
protesting about the high cost of fuel
latest figures show the average price at
the pump reached a new high of
191.5 pence per litre on sunday diesel
was 199 pence per liter this is all
after climate change protesters stopped
traffic earlier this year and the
government decided to bring in new
legislation against what it called
guerrilla protests
well also today you would have heard the
term green washing more and more
companies promoting that their products
or practices are greener than they
actually are but how damaging is green
washing well the outgoing chair of the
environment agency emma howard boyd says
businesses need to be transparent about
their net zero plans because otherwise
it's creating a full sense of confidence
about how the climate crisis is being
tackled
ecargo bikes and a team of on-foot
delivery staff are set to replace
thousands of amazon delivery vans in
london amazon will open its first micro
mobility hub in hackney in east london
as part of its efforts to cut its carbon
emissions the online retailer plans to
deliver half of its uk shipments with
net zero carbon by 2030 and all by 2040
now take a look at this world
record-breaking water lily it was grown
at kew gardens in london and it's got
scientists excited because it's been
revealed as a species new to science the
famous water lily has grown at the
botanic gardens for 177 years and it's
the first discovery of a new giant water
lily in over a century researchers on
the project have called the discovery
fundamentally important in the face of
fast
biodiversity loss
and before we go we want your climate
questions anything that's ever mystified
you or whatever you want to get to the
bottom of if you scan the qr code on
your screen right now you can send us
your questions some of which will be
answered on our new weekend climate show
hosted by the environment broadcaster
and author tom heap and you'll be able
to watch that on saturday and on sunday
at 3 30 here on sky news
well that's all from us for now thanks
for watching and we'll see you next time
bye
[Music]